hello everybody and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll and we're
getting good at this now we're getting
used to this so let's jump right in
today's big idea is time last week we
did space today we're doing time
probably not a big surprise but when we
did space we talked about you know why
there was space at all time is a little
bit different time is also similar to
space right I mean we live in a post
Einstein universe we've been we've had
that message beaten into us that space
and time are both part of one
four-dimensional space-time and yes
that's true and important the time is
also different than space in a lot of
ways so the discussion we're going to
have about time is very different than
the discussion we're going to have about
space I'm gonna be less concerned about
why time exists at all with the nature
of time what is it so with space that's
kind of obvious right space is where
other things are located time is a bit
more mysterious
despite the word time being the most
used noun in the English language and
most other languages I encourage you to
listen to the podcast interview I did
recently on mindscape with Lehrer board
Itsuki who is an expert on the language
of time and she'll talk about how the
word time and temporal language is used
in different cultures and so forth today
we're going to stick to the physics so
here's the thing you know we have a
certain point of view on space and time
they're both similar and different why
are they similar and different you know
we talk about space time in the modern
world but Isaac Newton could have talked
about space time right when we draw
these pictures space-time diagrams with
time going that way
space down here well space is every
slice of the space-time diagram right so
here's X and y but every moment of time
corresponds to a certain
three-dimensional space
okay so space sort of happens over and
over again you have a particle or
something like that that has some
trajectory and there it is when time is
that time okay so I've just drawn
space-time I didn't say anything about
relativity Einstein the speed of light
or anything like that
Isaac Newton could have drawn pictures
like this maybe he did draw up pictures
like this there is certainly a sense in
which time very naturally goes along
with space when you want to meet
somebody for coffee you have to say
where you're going to meet them where
you are in space but also when you're
gonna be there right what is the moment
of time that you're gonna be at the
coffee shop so to find yourself to do
something in the universe requires you
to specify the three numbers that tell
you where you're gonna be in space and
the one number that tells you where
you're going to be in time so there's a
very natural way in which there exist
space-time it is four-dimensional
nevertheless historically we did not
talk that way in fact as far as I can
tell it was until the late 19th century
when people began to talk about time in
ways similar to space and it wasn't even
scientists Edgar Allen Poe the poet and
short story writer wrote a weird poem
about cosmology called Eureka as one of
his last works a long definitive
statement on how he thought the universe
worked and he talks in there about how
time is a duration and that's very much
like space is a distance and I don't
know exactly what his motivation was for
doing that but he said those words HG
Wells of course in the time machine
circa I think 1895 definitely talked
about time and space as being two sides
of the same four-dimensional space-time
so before relativity came along but it
wasn't earlier that and I do sometimes
wonder about whether or not this idea
that time is similar to space coming up
rather late has something to do with the
fact that there aren't a lot of
time-travel stories in ancient cultures
right or in you know pre-modern cultures
let's put it that way there's not a lot
of stories about people traveling to
other times whereas now you can't swing
a cat without hitting a time travel
movie in the theater I think it's
because this idea that people really
didn't think of time other times as a
place to go right we didn't think about
time in the same way we think about
space so that's why I want to sort of
dig into a little bit here so why is
time diff
in space even though it's clearly
another place of a number you have to
give me to locate yourself it's also
different in various ways so I'll list a
few ways and then we'll sort of say well
maybe all these ways are kind of related
to each other so one way is we move
through time of course we can move
through space also but we move through
time kind of whether we like it or not
right we can choose to travel through
space where we can just choose to sit on
our butts or there could be a global
pandemic that enforces sitting on our
butts and not moving through space very
much but pandemic or not we're going to
age we're going to move through time one
second per second okay and the reason
why I write one second per second it
just seems like obvious pathology etc
people sometimes ask about the speed at
which we move through time which is that
a bad thing to ask speed is distance
divided by time speed by its definition
velocity rate these are a amount of
space traversed per unit time there is
no such thing by definition as the rate
at which we move through time unless you
give it some thought ologists notion
like one second per second but the point
is there is an inevitability about it
you can avoid hitting an obstacle that
is in your path in space you cannot
avoid hitting tomorrow that seems to be
a feature of time another feature is
that one moment depends on the next this
is a we're getting a little deeper and
more important now well on the previous
one I should say the usual way we think
about it what I mean by that is you know
if I have an object here here's an Apple
pencil that I use to make these videos I
can be pretty sure that the stuff out of
which the pencil is made will still
exist one second from now there's a few
you know exceptions to that if a global
if I you know if the false vacuum decays
or something like that black hole
swallows us up but roughly speaking
things tend to persist through time in
the more formal way of saying
in the laplacian Newtonian point of view
on physics we can go from what happens
at one moment to predict what will
happen at the next moment towards a
retro dick would happen at the previous
moment there is no structure like that
for space the fact that there exists a
pencil right here does not tell me
anything at all about what is next to it
I can imagine all sorts of spatial
configurations with very different
things from one point to another so this
dependence that we have through time
distinguishes time from space
another feature is that somehow we think
the past is settled the past already
happened right and it's again the
language that we have that was not
invented to talk scientifically or
philosophically about time language
comes from ordinary use embedded into
this language is a very definite notion
of how time works so it's hard even to
say it out loud but the past is settled
whereas the future is up for grabs
I'm intentionally being casual about
that the future hasn't happened yet
but we have a feeling that we can affect
the future we have a feeling that there
are choices we could make that could
have an influence over what happens next
or even if it's not put in personal
Antep eccentric terms we have a feeling
that there are causes or events right
HAP that happened right now at one
moment that have an impact on effects in
the future
causes precede effects we don't think
that anything we can do right now or
choose to do right now can change the
past okay and I know there's some
freewill skeptics out there that says
nothing you can do now could change the
future either so put that aside for the
moment what I mean is we I'm not trying
to do here is describe the reality what
I'm trying to do here to describe our
impressions okay we talk a language that
says I can choose to watch this video or
not I can choose to make this video or
not I could choose to do various things
but only toward the future we only speak
a language of causal influence over the
future whereas we think the past is done
there's nothing we can do to affect it
we can have memories of it we can have
records we can have photo
we have artifacts fossils history books
and so forth none of which we have about
the future so this there seems to be
this imbalance whereas so this is a
difference between time and space
because there's nothing like that in
space there's nothing like that about my
location here in space that draws a huge
distinction between left and right in
the same way that my location in time
draws a huge distinction between past
and future so all of these together I
think what we can do is add them up to
the question let's put it this way I was
gonna say is time real but that's
begging a certain question are other
times real do they really exist so what
I mean is forget about like the deep
down definition of what reality is we're
not gonna get that philosophical right
now let's imagine there is a sense in
which I truly believe that there's
something called the room next door and
there's stuff in it and that's real okay
let's get that again it's a it's the
fault notion it's the informal everyday
notion nothing very very sophisticated
we have a different notion when it comes
to time we don't have any controversy
over the reality of what's at other
locations in space but we treat other
times as something that may or may not
be sensibly considered as real is the
past real is the future real are they as
real as the present these are all good
open questions so you won't be surprised
to learn that different people have
different attitudes about these
questions and basically all the
possibilities have their defenders I'm
not going to go into a sort of a full
detailed account of all the different
possible ways you can answer this
question are other times real there's
the question but let's focus on the two
big obvious ones one is called present
ISM and the other is called eternalism
sometimes this is called the block
universe perspective and the basic idea
here you can guess from what I've
already said and from the labels what is
going on here a prescient test says if
this is your space-time diagram and this
is one particular moment
here's space your people in space doing
things a present test is going to say
this is what's real the future
everything up here and the past
everything down they're not real not
real yet you would say about the future
or not real anymore you would say about
the past we're not denying that they
were real or will be real but we're
saying when we talk about what the world
is as a present is we say the world is
the stuff that exists right now that is
the world that is reality the stuff that
exists right now occurs over and over
again slightly different configurations
things move okay so we use time to label
the different manifestations the
different instantiations appearances of
the world but at any one moment just
that one moment is what is real and this
distinction between past present and
future is really really deep and
important and of central importance to
metaphysics and and philosophy in
reality and physics and science and all
those things where as an eternal list
will draw the same space-time diagram so
here's time here's a certain moment of
space there's a person okay
there's time but they will say look the
whole thing is just as real okay there's
no difference in eternalism between the
past the between the reality at least of
the past present and future
so I'm not drawing it very well but the
idea is that there is a four dimensional
block did you do there it is and past
president future Hall
equally real to an eternal list so an
eternal ax says the only thing special
about the present moment is that it is
the present moment to you there are past
moments here's a past moment and there's
an immense temptation to say the past is
still real or the past is real now or
the present and past are real at the
same time none of those is the right way
of saying it it's not that the past is
still real it's just the past is real
that's it that's what you say the future
is real there's no difference in the
levels of reality according to an
eternal list or to a block universe
person between the past present and
future okay
and you might very well wonder who cares
that's a perfectly fair question to ask
about this but let but let's imagine
that we care about the difference
between these two things and then we'll
offer some reasons to think either one
but again I'm not here to tell you the
final answer about this I'm an eternal
list on a block universe person and I'll
mention offhandedly some of the reasons
why but really I want you to be thinking
about the existence of this question
there is also by the way another point
of view I'll draw this other point of
view that I will erase it because it's
just sort of a curiosity you can say
well you can take seriously this idea
the time is going forward and the past
is fixed the past is in the books but
the future is up for grabs and say okay
what that means to me is that the past
is real but not the future so I can say
here's what's real
not yet real up here this is called the
growing block universe and it's a
perfectly respectable position but I
think once you've gone all the way to
saying the past is real why not include
the future as well so these are the
these are various options that are on
the table but I'm not gonna belabor all
the different there's more than this
believe me there's many many more that
you could imagine being converted to
okay so why what are that what are the
different aspects of this what are the
different features of it
these are ancient perspectives you know
and I'm not gonna I'm hesitating here
talking because this way of slicing the
options in to present ISM and eternalism
is very closely related to some other
ways of slicing but not exactly the same
as and I'm gonna smush them all together
I'm not going to be very careful about
distinguishing between what we talked
about here but roughly speaking this is
Heraclitus if you go back to ancient
Greek thinking about philosophy and
physics
Heraclitus was the ancient Greek
philosopher who emphasized the primacy
of change what is important is change
and so Erich latest makes the point that
if you think about a river okay and you
say what is real and you might say well
there's a river and then you come back
the next day it's the same river there
it is and Heraclitus says no no no it's
a totally different River it's a it's a
river that is at a different moment in
time the atoms he would know about the
atoms but the water has moved there
slight differences in the nature of the
river there's a completely different
thing going on as far as Heraclitus is
concerned change and flux are what are
really important part minute ease is the
guy who's held up as the anti Heraclitus
par manatee says there is no such thing
as change there is an eternal reality
these roughly roughly roughly map on to
present ISM and eternalism and more
recently there is a guy names was his
what is his name John Ellis MacTaggert I
knew his last name but not his first
names I'm trying to write down the first
name so they don't forget them like poor
Joseph Louis Lagrange whose name I
always forget so McTaggart has what he
calls the a theory of time and the B
theory of time Mike Haggar was a
philosopher in the early 20th century
and his point was to argue that time was
not real that the very notion of time
was self contradictory so he had an a
series and a B series the a series was
thinking of time centered on the present
moment so you think of time is now
future and past this is the tensed
theory of time or tensed way of talking
about it past present future and this is
the tencel
theory of time because if you want you
can just put a coordinate on the time
coordinate of the universe you know
going from zero at the Big Bang to 14
billion years now to the future and you
can label different moments in time by
their time coordinate but this notion of
past present and future is not central
to the conception of what time is and
McTaggart has a bunch of arguments he
says clearly the B theory is wrong
clearly the a Theory's right but then he
says the a theory is mutually is
internally incoherent so it can't be
right either therefore there's no such
thing as time his famous paper is called
the unreality of time so I think that's
a little silly the particular conclusion
I'm certainly not doing justice so any
pro mcdaggett McTaggart Aryans out there
sorry about that
the question of whether time is real let
me just brush over it very quickly of
course time is real come on give me a
break everyone in the world uses time
all the time you can have a more
sophisticated point of view where you
say that maybe time is not fundamental
maybe it emerges from something more
important but you can't say that time is
not real there's a temptation even among
block universe people especially among
block universe people like myself to say
well if every moment of time is equally
real then time is not real time is just
an illusion the idea that we flow
through time that we move it or that
time moves around us moves past us those
can't be right if the universe is
eternal and real at equally real at
every single moment but that's just
crazy talk at every single moment I the
person that is me at that moment does
divide the universe into past present
and future that person knows perfectly
well what it means to say your TV show
comes on at 8:00 p.m. I used to say the
movie came on at 8:00 p.m. but now that
we're all under lockdown we watch our TV
shows at 8:00 p.m.
using time in a very pragmatic everyday
way is clearly necessary and for me
that's more than enough to say the time
is real it's not an illusion it might
not be fundamental there might be a
better deeper more comprehensive way of
talking about the notion that we talk
about time especially once we
to quantum mechanics and quantum
cosmology and so forth but obviously
time is real give me a break
okay so I'm not very pro of McTaggart
Arian having said that let me put a
footnote on that there is something to
Heraclitus --is point of view where he
says the river tomorrow is not the same
as the river today and this drives home
especially when we start talking about
personal identity forget about the
identity of the river what about
ourselves right we certainly have a very
strong feeling that it makes sense to
talk about who I was a day ago or a year
ago right there's something called me
and that person has an extent through
time I might have changed but there is a
meanness and identity that flows through
time from the past to the future that's
again a very very strong feeling that we
have if you're really strict about it as
an eternal list what you would say is
what really exists is me now me at a
certain time of day but there's another
thing that exists which is me as I was a
day ago or a year ago these are
different things because they're at
different locations in time there's a
relationship between them just like
there's a relationship between different
atoms different molecules in the Apple
pencil here okay but that doesn't mean
that they're an identity in and of
themselves at a fundamental level right
we can choose to separate out the
different atoms and think about them in
different ways they are they have a
separate identity likewise I would argue
we can choose to treat me now and me a
year ago and me five years ago as
different things the reason why some of
you will know the reason why I care
about this particular issue is because
when it comes to the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
there will not only be Me's at different
moments of time but there will be Me's
in different branches of the
wavefunction and those are different
means they're not me does not the same
person you know they're separated just
let some identical twin would be a
different person even though we came
from the same egg okay
but they share a relationship and so I
think that once you get sophisticated
about the notion of personal identity
through time you understand that it's
about relationships not about some
metaphysical essence that passes from
moment to moment and the same is true
about different copies of you in
different branches of the wave function
of the universe okay why would anybody
be tempted to go into this crazy view
that all times are created equal when I
had this strong feeling for my everyday
experience that now is what really
exists well the answer is because the
laws of physics don't distinguish
between different times okay I'm I'm not
sure exactly how best to put this the
word distinguish is doing a lot of work
there but the laws of physics don't
distinguish between different times time
appears in the laws of physics okay we
talked about in the Newtonian paradigm
you give me the initial conditions the
position velocity or position of
momentum and I can chug through time I
can evolve the particle or the set of
particles forward or backward so but
that what what appears if I say right F
equals MA force equals mass times
acceleration
well acceleration is the derivative of
velocity with respect to time there it
is time appearing in the equation but
what appears is the notion of time not
any one particular time so this is the
rate of change of velocity as time
passes but this equation is the same
equation at every moment of time okay
that's what it means to say the laws of
physics do not distinguish between
different moments of time they do not
pick out a preferred moment of time just
like when we were talking about Galilean
relativity there's no location in space
that is picked out there is no velocity
no inertial frame of reference that is
picked out there is no time that is
picked out either so the laws of physics
don't point to now as anything special
in the world they treat the universe as
more or less the same at every moment
the laws treated
more or less equally at every moment of
time the argument that you should treat
all moments of time equally becomes even
stronger when relativity comes along and
this is cheating because we haven't
talked about relativity yet but in
relativity I'll just tell you one
feature of it if you were to draw a
spacetime diagram X and T okay Einstein
says unlike Newton who said space exists
time exists and there separate Einstein
says space and time both exist as part
of four-dimensional space-time why does
he want to say that I'm hesitating
because he didn't want to say that when
he first invented what we now know is
special relativity when he first put it
in his final form there were other
people like Lorentz and Punk RA and
Fitzgerald and other who contributed to
it he didn't like the idea that you
should think about special relativity in
terms of space-time that was an
invention by Minkowski Ben clusky if you
want to be German about it Hermann
Minkowski who's actually Einstein's
professor right older than Einstein it
was minkovski who was a mathematician
who said there's a nice mathematical
formalism that lets you think about
Einstein's special theory of relativity
in terms of a single four-dimensional
space-time and he I don't advocate this
quite strongly
Einstein was initially reluctant to go
that far he had some equations they
worked that's all he needed of course by
the time ten years later when he was
inventing general relativity the idea of
space time was absolutely crucial so he
did accept it anyway the point here this
is special relativity forget about
general relativity so this is 1905 and
what between Einstein and Minkowski what
they realized was the splitting of
space-time into moments of constant time
which we then call space is not absolute
is not built-in to the laws of nature it
depends on the perspective of an
observer so implicitly when you draw
this picture of space-time as I drew it
you're imagining this is what is
observed by an observer that is
basically stationary from this
perspective that is staying at the same
ocation in space if you had an observer
that was moving at some velocity then
they would if you asked them the
question what are moments of equal time
moments of simultaneity all throughout
space then if your observer is doing
something like this
okay here's a different observer this is
the weird part
they don't rotate the axes like you
would on a Euclidean plane otherwise it
would just be space we were talking
about but because it's space-time they
say that a constant moment of time looks
like this so they would say this is call
it T prime here I'll be nice to you I
will make a different color so here's
this observer moving along this
trajectory and they would call this T
Prime and they would call this X Prime
and so this set of points of space-time
are to the moving observer but they
would think of as the universe at one
moment in time in other words the way
that we take space-time and divide it up
into moments of time is not built in to
the fabric of reality it depends on the
perspective and of an observer but a
present issed someone who thinks that
only the present moment is real whole
has a problem with this right I mean if
you thought only the present moment is
real who's present moment is it that is
real present tests are very stubborn and
very clever and they have figured out
ways to deal with this but I would say I
would not be a present test even if it
were just Newtonian physics but I could
get it I mean I could appreciate the
importance of it but once you're into
relativity being a present issed is very
very difficult dividing up the universe
is a human construction dividing up the
universe into moments of time it doesn't
seem to be something that is really has
a lot of metaphysical umph about the
nature of reality okay so once
relativity comes along sensible people
become eternalists in that way and okay
we're still okay that's a little
argument in favor of eternalism but you
know we still feel this diff
it's between space and time and so we're
still a little bit reluctant to actually
dive in to this eternal list perspective
and I find that in these situations
where there's there's a question of you
know reality or philosophy or whatever
face facing us as people who care about
physics it helps to operationalize it
helps to actually say what really
happens in the world that that what do
we get out of talking about the world
one way or the other
I'm not against thinking metaphysically
about these questions I think it's
crucially important to do so I think the
whole point of science is to understand
what is happening really what is what is
the best language and and formalism we
have for grasping reality and asking
what is real is an important part of
that but we can become we can break
anchor right we can get unmoored from
reality unless we bring our language
back into questions about what do we see
what happens what can we touch what
becomes tangible so let's think about
how we measure time well we know right
how we measure time is through clocks
what is a clock clock is something that
measures time so it seems a little bit
circular what do we mean by a clock you
know when we have space it's a little
bit more obvious right we we build
something some object that has some
integrity that doesn't change that much
over time and we say this is a standard
unit of measure like a ruler okay like a
measuring rod so very often in
relativity people will be talking about
rods and clocks the rod they mean is a
ruler or something that has a fixed
length and you can put a certain number
of them next to each other to measure
the distance between something clocks
are a little bit more subtle I mean
things change with time but things
change with time in different ways
how do you know what counts as a clock
and what is just changing in some
arbitrary way so a clock is something
that changes reliably
and predictably with time okay but what
does that mean well what it means is
that clocks are things that change
reliably and predictably with respect to
other clocks still seems like cheating I
know but in this case it's not it
becomes not cheating what do I mean how
could this not be cheating how could
this not be circular the point is our
universe is full of clocks there are
things in the universe that do change in
predictable ways especially in
repetitive ways right the most obvious
one in the world is here is the Sun
rising in the east okay there's a
landscape my drawing skills you know but
okay the Sun rises in the east etc we
know that the earth rotates around its
axis and it revolves around the Sun and
we know furthermore that these happen in
a repetitive predictable way with
respect to each other you might you know
you might be tempted to say how many
times does the earth rotate around its
axis every time it revolves around the
Sun and you might say well 365 that's
the number of days in a year but that's
not exactly right of course so there is
such a thing called leap year right
because it's really 365.25 times that
you see the Sun go up and go down
therefore you have to add a day every
four years because it's roughly a
quarter of a year extra that it takes
quarter of a day extra that it takes but
it's worse than that because if you
think about it if the Sun if the earth
were not rotating at all if it were only
revolving around the Sun you would still
see the Sun go up and down once per year
right so zero rotations still means one
cycle of the Sun and that's the
difference between a solar day which is
how long it is between the Sun going up
and returning to the same spot in the
sky and what is called a sidereal day so
a sidereal day is the this is the time
it takes the earth to rotate with
respect to the rest of the universe with
respect to the fixed stars if you want
to put it that way and because of that
extra
a it turns out that it is 366 rotations
of the earth every time it revolves once
around the Sun 360 6.25 Siberia days ok
anyway the point is its predictable
right the first clocks came to us from
astronomy from looking at the sky and
seeing how long it took things to happen
the fact that there are two things going
on the rotation of the earth and the
revolution of the earth around the Sun
is enough to say there are clocks and in
fact the universe is full of clocks
atoms and nuclei make the best clocks
but a pretty good clock comes from a
pendulum right so if you have a ceiling
and you tie something to the ceiling by
a rope or something like that so you put
some heavy object on it
this can rock back and forth and it
turns out that the length of the rope
does matter to how long it rocks but the
amplitude does not so if you have one of
these pendulums and you nudge it just a
little bit and let it rock back and
forth and ask how long does it take to
rock back and forth then you take the
same exact pendulum and push a little
bit more so it's wrote it's rocking back
and forth more it takes the same amount
of time the pendulum will move faster
but because it's going further it takes
the same amount of time so there's
something called the frequency of the
pendulum that as long as it keeps at the
same length you're gonna be more or less
constant this was figured out by Galileo
one of our heroes obviously in this
series and the legend I'm not sure how
true this is legend was he was going to
church
like any good Pisan young boy but he was
bored so he looked at the chandelier in
the church going back and forth and he
timed it using his heartbeat using his
pulse and he noticed it on different
days depending on the you know they
would have to lower the chandeliers to
light the candles they didn't have
electric lights so they were lower the
chandeliers pull them back up and as
they after they were pulling back up
there'd be a little oscillation to the
chandelier galileo says that the period
is more or less constant now of course
this is a physicists pendulum so we'll
say a Proxima
the constant there is air resistance and
stuff like that
but more or less pendulums with
relatively small oscillations are good
clocks that's why pendulums appear in
grandfather clocks and things like that
a mechanical wristwatch has a little
spring that goes back and forth
oscillates very very quickly at a
predictable rate that's what makes it a
good clock so the universe is full of
clocks with respect to each other they
can tick off moments of time and that is
how we measure it now I should say
parenthetically not all clocks are
repetitive right there are there's such
thing as an hourglass you just take the
hourglass flip it over you know that
it's gonna take a certain amount of time
to go down but it doesn't automatically
flip itself it doesn't do the same thing
over and over again I used to believe
that in the brain there were all sorts
of oscillations at different frequencies
that helped us keep time I I think
that's not right I believe from talking
to neuroscientists that what happens in
the brain to actually give us the
ability to measure short intervals of
time is something closer to an hourglass
than to an oscillating clock back and
forth we have various things going on in
our brain where a lot of charge builds
up and sort of if it builds up enough it
will collapse and that happens over a
certain interval of time so there's a
fascinating relationship between
physicists time and psychological time
we're not going to get into that very
deeply here but it is an obvious
question to ask you know are we are full
of clocks they're more like our glasses
than pendulums or Springs but we we can
feel time passing it seems to us that
under different circumstances we feel
time passing at different rates why is
that is that something about time is it
something about consciousness you know
because it's psychology and neuroscience
these questions are much harder than
physics questions are so we don't know
the final answers though there's been a
lot of interesting work done you know
one famous experiment was done by David
Eagleman neuroscientist he is fascinated
by the idea that when we're in danger
when the adrenaline is pumping through
us and you know we're in high-intensity
situations time seems to slow down so he
did an experiment
he wanted to test this idea by throwing
people out of buildings so in other
words you have tall building here's a
person standing there and you
psychologist neuroscientist you push
them off and then they fall down they
land and you ask is their experience of
time somehow different because they're
scared of dying now if you're a good
psychologist do you get approval from
the review board and you put a
trampoline or something down here so
they're safe and that's what he did so
what Eagleman did was what he wanted to
see was is it true that as the
adrenaline is flowing through you etc
you literally speed up okay is it
possible that time seems to flow more
slowly when we're in these
high-intensity situations because we are
moving more quickly so there are more
tics of our clock than there are of an
ordinary well calibrated wristwatch or
something like that so what he did was
he below a machine where people could
see flashing lights and they would flash
at a certain speed and then the speed
could be so fast you couldn't perceive
what was going on or it could be slow
enough that you could just get enough
information to perceive what was going
on and this was a quick enough
experiment that you could literally do
it while you are falling onto the
trampoline or onto the big puffy thing
that will protect you at the bottom of
the building the answer is no you do not
speed up you are not your ability to
discern small moments of time does not
seem to be any better even when your
adrenaline is flowing and you're falling
off the building then it is when you're
sitting still in a psychology laboratory
instead what seems to happen is that in
these high-intensity situations you
accumulate more memories you have a very
vivid feeling sensorium about what is
going on around you and it's not that in
the moment time slows down
it's that retrospectively it seems to
have taken longer it seems and this is
other research that points in the same
direction but again I'm not going to say
it's absolutely true but it seems that
our retrospective feeling about how long
something took is related to the novelty
and the number of new memories we
accumulate over time so you can get
bored like you mean a long airplane
flight and it can seem to stretch
forever exactly because nothing is
happening it's the same thing over and
over again there is no novelty but in
retrospect you don't have a feeling that
it seemed to be a long amount of time
because nothing new was happening this
is this is supposed to also perhaps
explain why time seems to go faster when
you're older right like when you're
young the summer seemed to stretch out
forever when you're older it seems to go
by really quickly because you're seeing
less novelty when you're older because
you've been to the beach before when
you're older mmm
fewer new memories are being accumulated
so time seems to pass more quickly again
I don't want to be too definitive about
this because no one is and I'm not an
expert on them but the point is our
psychological appreciation of time is
something that is related to but still
very very different from the physical
notion of time passing okay so that was
certainly an aside oops so but let me go
back to the pendulum then because
there's something I want to say about it
which is imagining make a movie of the
pendulum okay imagine you have the
pendulum going back and forth and make a
movie of it and someone plays the movie
and for you and you say yes there you go
pendulum and they say to you aha I
tricked you I was playing the movie
backwards right if you have a perfect
physicists pendulum where there's no air
resistance it just rocks back and forth
with the same amplitude forever and you
could play it backwards and no one would
ever know because a movie of a backwards
going pendulum looks exactly the same as
the movie before we're going pendulum
that is a reflection of the fact that
the laws of physics not only do they not
distinguish between different moments of
time but the laws of physics treat past
and future equivalently in other words
if you changed time as your coordinate
in different moments of moments
different moments of the history of the
universe if you change time to - time
the laws of physics would not change the
laws of physics would be invariant under
that distinction from the laplacian
point-of-view if you know what's going
on at one moment of time this is why you
can chug forward in time or backward in
time equally well now we know that this
idea that the past and future are
equivalent is utterly incompatible with
our everyday notions of time with our
everyday experience of time that's not
what we feel right like we already said
the past seems to be embedded done
finished untouchable the future seems to
be up for grabs something it hasn't
happened yet something that is malleable
and changeable this is something called
dramatic reveal the arrow of time you
were waiting for this the whole time I
know the aro time is simply a catch-all
phrase for all the different ways in
which the past and future are different
from each other despite the fact the
laws of physics treat past and future
equally equivalently there is in our
everyday experience of the world a huge
difference between past and future so
one obvious example of this is you have
to work really hard to find a pendulum
that is good enough that if you made a
movie of it and played it backwards no
one would know right most things you do
in the universe if you take a movie of
them and play them backwards everyone
knows if you take a movie of an egg
breaking or someone falling into a
swimming pool
or a plant growing or cars driving down
the street and you played those movie
backwards those movies backward everyone
would instantly know that you would
reverse to the direction of time we were
younger we all grow older we all
remember the past we all et cetera we
experience the past and future very very
differently that's the arrow of time
back in the day before Newtonian physics
came along there was no one who wondered
about the arrow of time because they
were mostly present ists right they
mostly thought that the what is real
that the real world is a
three-dimensional space with stuff in it
time is just a way of talking about what
happens physics comes along and says
number one
actually it's probably better to think
in terms of space and time as being kind
of similar things ways of locating
yourself in the universe and number two
the laws of physics don't distinguish
between moving forward and moving
backward in time now there's a puzzle
about the arrow of time where does it
come from okay well I will tell you the
answer I will tell you my favorite
answer but we'll have to talk about it
more to get into details and guess what
we have more videos ahead of us in which
we can talk about it
so the basic answer is entropy entropy
is very roughly speaking a measure of
the disorderliness the randomness in a
collection of stuff so if you have a box
of gas and all of the molecules of the
gas are somehow in the corner and
there's just vacuum all around them this
is low entropy this is not very random
whereas if you have a box of gas and all
the molecules of gas are randomly
distributed throughout the box this is
high entropy and it will not surprise
you to learn that in closed systems
entropy increases almost really entropy
never decreases all by itself is this
rule which we call the second law of
thermodynamics the first law of
thermodynamics is just that energy is
conserved you knew that already so the
second law of thermodynamics entropy
tends to increase and close to some at
least it doesn't go down things go from
more orderly to less orderly that is a
law look it says law right there it's a
law of physics that does tell the
difference between the past and the
future so how could I say the laws of
physics treat past and future
equivalently clearly the second law of
thermodynamics does not so this is the
project of people like Ludwig Boltzmann
in the 1870s the the 19th century more
generally Maxwell and Thompson and other
people Gibbs contributed to this idea
but they what they wanted to do
was to reconcile this idea that the laws
of physics treat past and future
equivalently which is what is handed
down to us by Newtonian dynamics by the
laws of classical mechanics with this
idea that in fact there is a macroscopic
feature of the world where the
difference between past and future is
hugely important and roughly speaking
the answer is this that the right way to
think thing about phase space okay think
about for some system with maybe a large
number of particles there's a large
number of things that could happen
roughly speaking there are positions and
there are momenta I'll put them in
little braces to let you know this is
for many many particles at once and when
you look at a system like when you look
at a cup of coffee with cream and
coffees classic example you don't see
precisely what point to face space it's
in because you can't see every molecule
that is in the cream or the coffee you
see some coarse-grained features you see
some incomplete information okay so if
Boltzmann says is what we're gonna do
with the entire phase space is be honest
we're gonna say I can't see exactly
where in phase space this system is what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna divide phase
space up into what are called macro
States and a macro state is a collection
of many many different points in phase
space that all look the same to me
macroscopically so if I change around
the arrangement of the molecules of
cream or the molecules of coffee so as
to still keep the macroscopic appearance
of the cup of coffee the same then I'm
in the same macro state and I can
imagine there's different macro States
sort of embedded inside each other where
the cream of the coffee are mixing
together more and more thoroughly and
then he says the entropy is just the
size of the macro state in other words
the more microstates are in a macro
state the bigger the entropy is I left
some room here because technically it's
the logarithm of the size of the macro
state I'm not to tell you what a
logarithm
but you can look it up but anyway it's a
it's a measure of the size of the
microstate so basically a macro state
which is very tiny is low entropy
because there aren't that many ways to
arrange things to look like that a macro
state where there are many many
arrangements that look exactly the same
is high entropy this is the
formalization of the idea intuitively
that entropy is a measure of
disorderliness
really entropy is a measure of the
number of indistinguishable microstates
that are members of that macro state so
Boltzmann says now I can tell you why
entropy tends to increase because if
entropy is the size of the macro state
if I start let me change colors if I
start in a very low entropy macro state
and I just let things go I just let the
system evolve without directing it in
any way it will almost inevitably and
you can do the math it's extremely
extremely likely the system will evolve
into a bigger macro state entropy will
tend to go up so that's crucially
important because on the one hand he is
reconciling the Newtonian dynamics of
the microstate with the apparent fact
that entropy increases but on the other
he's saying that the second law is not
really a law it's possible that just by
your random wanderings you will find
yourself going from high entropy into
low entropy it's just really really
unlikely okay so the second law is a
statistical law but if you again if you
run the numbers once the number of atoms
or molecules in your system is bigger
than a hundred the chances that you
dramatically decrease in entropy are
infinitesimally tiny in the age of the
universe so there's good news bad news
here the good news is we have explained
why the entropy increases over time
despite the fact that the underlying
laws of physics are completely
reversible or completely agnostic about
past versus future the bad news is there
are two big questions that are left over
okay.i what we what Boltzmann explained
was so here the open questions
what Boltzmann explained was why entropy
would tend to increase if you start in a
low entropy state why do you start in a
low entropy state now there's a little
bit of a cheat here because I use the
word start ex post facto if you have at
one end of time a low entropy state and
at the other end of time a high entropy
state you will always define the past to
be the direction of lower entropy so
it's not that you start with low entropy
is that there is low entropy at all at
any point on your trajectory because if
you think about it if you find yourself
in this picture in this medium entropy
state okay and you didn't know anything
else if you didn't know what the past
was like or what the future was like the
simplest way simplest trajectory the
most likely trajectory to live on is one
that goes to a future higher entropy
state but also one that came from a past
higher entropy state so if all you had
was Boltzmann's division of phase space
up into macro States you would say well
both the past and the future are equally
higher entropy most likely we don't
think that's true we think that in the
real world there was a lower entropy
beginning and so the name for that idea
is the past hypothesis that we started
with a low entropy state why do we call
it a hypothesis what might it be true
future video we'll talk about that we're
not going to talk about it right now but
this is an open question and it's a
question for cosmology the universe
began in a low entropy state 14 billion
years ago nobody knows why that's an
open question the other open question is
are are all manifestations of the arrow
of time versions of the arrow of time
explicable or explained by increasing
entropy
so I said so I think the answer this one
is yes therefore I will sometimes to say
as if it's true but you know to be fair
it's not proven we're not sure that this
is true there remember I mentioned
different manifestations of the arrow
time I can causally affect things in the
future but not the past I can remember
the past but not the future we were all
little babies in the past role be
wrinkly old people in the future there's
many different versions of the arrow of
time psychological etc I claim that all
of them or because of the second law of
thermodynamics that ultimately the
second law of thermodynamics the fact
that entropy is increasing under gret
underlies or grounds all the different
versions of the second of the arrow of
time but we haven't proven that we
haven't shown that this is ongoing
research so for those of you out there
who are interested in nature of time
there's a lot to be done right I mean
what time is we haven't even touched on
we sort of used the everyday notion
there's a label on points in the
universe just as for space you can get
deeply into quantum gravity and ask
about whether it's emerging likewise you
can do that for time but even if you
accept what time is as a smooth
parameter that tells you when you are in
the universe there's still these huge
open questions why was the entropy so
low is the change of entropy enough to
explain all the different versions of
the arrow of time we'll say more about
this in later videos but still the point
here is that it's an open question
there's a lot about time that we have
yet to understand